ladies and gentlemen thank you uh for
joining us tonight we have a very
special treat
again my favorite thing during these
times is when uh a guest comes here
in person very funny gentleman and a
friend of mine
has joined us tonight at the largo
theater i'm happy about this
it's always exciting when a friend comes
to visit yeah yeah
and and when joel comes too
my guest tonight calls himself an actor
and a comedian
what settle down his new movie happily
is out this friday please welcome
our good friend it's a legal thing
joel mchale joel you look fantastic
thanks for coming in person
oh what the [ __ ] oh come on that was
like four insults
no no no it was three insults okay
you're right yeah thank you
you look amazing and uh and and thank
you for being here
yeah i know i dressed up yeah i see that
and uh you decided to
on st patrick's day dressed like a a
british kernel
yeah no i am this is a uh this is the
only green i had
this is the only green shirt i had which
is fine and then
this is an old sweater that i found
and uh well i thought i had found it and
then a guy started yelling
at a restaurant that's my sweater but i
just kept it uh you don't really need to
wear green
on st patrick's day because you look
like uh
like some sort of crazy monster
leprechaun that lives underneath a
bridge
yeah well thank you for that you're
welcome um
but i felt it was my job my duty to
represent the good people
of ireland are you 100 i am 106
irish wow yeah it's uh i as i've
i've said i am dangerously inbred it's
been irish people
marrying irish people uh in america for
about 110 years that's and that's why
your eyes are like that
yeah yeah and it's why i can't see you
right now that's
i can't see you by the way the audience
is really
the audience is adding a lot to this
magical mixture it
looks like you've been kidnapped by
aliens and they
decide they were like he is a tv show
host make it his home
right on our planet like he has on his
planet yes
and they they put these two-dimensional
people there and when i say
two-dimensional i'm including andy
richter hey andy
hi guys who is that it's
joel mchale oh joel mchale how are you i
was in spy kids four
i remember no you don't okay yeah i
don't i don't
now is it true that you were only in spy
kids four because you were asked to
leave spy kids three is that true they
just
they slid you over one spy kid he hit he
hid in a bin
you showed up at spy kids three and you
went over to catering and you hid in a
casserole
and a casserole tray bin and that is why
you were in spy kids 4. it was a
screen actors guild standard stowaway
contract
that if you sign the addendum and you're
there you're in the sequel
you know even though my character was
killed in spy kids 3. uh yeah but you
came back and god bless you